- Coral's kind of like
the trees of a forest.
They're just the backbone of
the whole tropical ecosystem.
And if they disappear,
we're in a lot of trouble.
My name's Ken Nedimyer, I'm the founder
of the Coral Restoration Foundation.
The reason I'm doing this,
I was, I’d grown up diving, spent
a lot of time in the water.
One, two, three.
(splashing)
I've basically watched
the coral reefs dying.
As the reefs died, the
fish didn't come back,
and I realized, I'm
tired of watching it die,
I need to do something about it.
And so I developed this
whole idea of growing corals
in an offshore nursery and
replanting them on the reef.
- [Man] And so you're
kind of like a farmer?
- I'm a farmer. (laughing)
Yeah, we grow corals just like a farm.
There's a good time of year to plant,
and there's a harvest time.
And we have five offshore
nurseries in the Keys.
Each tree can hold 100
corals.
We start with little
fragments that we collect.
And after six to nine
months, maybe a year,
that fragment has turned into a colony
that might have 100
centimeters of growth on it.
We cut that off, and then
we plant it out on the reef.
So we just harvested some corals,
and we're gonna take
'em out to Pickles Reef
right now and plant them.
We've got a couple
thousand of 'em out there
that we've already planted
and we're gonna add some more.
It is a bit of gardening
when you put the corals
back out on the reef you're saying,
“Ah, I think they would
look nice over there,
and that would look nice over there;” and,
some of it's based on
what used to be there
and what should be there, and
that's how we do our planting.
We planted 20,000 already this year.
We'll plant 25,000 next year.
Those corals will
probably spawn next year.
Part of the long-range
goal is to get the corals
reproducing on their own.
I'm excited every time I get in the water,
whether I'm going to work in the nursery
or whether I'm planting corals or just
looking for new areas to plant.
A lot of people said, “Oh
you can never do that,
it'll never work, can't do
it on a big enough scale;”
and I think I've proven
that it can be done.
And if we can train enough
people and teach enough people
in other places, I think we can really see
a significant turnaround.
Another day, another coral.
(mellow piano)